canadians are telling the prime minister
they want to get back to work they want
to get back to normal life that's why
we're seeing demonstrations not only in
ottawa but right across the country the
prime minister has caused division by
overtly politicizing vaccines and the
pandemic and calling these canadians
names and now he's saying these protests
really aren't his problem they're the
provinces or maybe even the cities
when will the prime minister stop hiding
show up for canadians show some
leadership and fix the mess that he's
created
[Applause]
the honorable minister
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker and i appreciate
the question i think that what we have
to ask at this moment in time is what
needs to get done to get canadians safe
and out of this pandemic and what we
know is the best way we can get out of
this pandemic is to get vaccinated we're
all tired we're all frustrated but we
have to ask how we can continue to
sacrifice to keep those safe around us
to make sure that we follow public
health measures and do our best to get
out of this pandemic keeping as many
people safe and alive as possible
the honorable leader of the opposition
dr tam and other health officials across
the country have started to change their
language on lifting restrictions
according to dr tam things like vaccine
mandates should be re-evaluated
countries around the world have started
to lift restrictions or actually end
them all together so can the prime
minister tell canadians today when the
government will quickly respond to our
public health officials and begin to
lift all the restrictions that they've
imposed on
[Applause]
well mr canadians
let's be clear
that the mandates most of which she's
speaking of are provincial in nature
that the mandates
[Applause]
[Music]
of commons one word
[Applause]
can we can we go ahead
okay
the honorable
leader of the opposition just asked a
question she'd like to hear what has to
be said in response to her question
please
let the honorable government house
leader
answer so she he can she can hear it the
honourable government house speaker i
heard some yelling that they want to end
the mandate for uh for truckers to be
able to get vaccinated but i would point
out to the honorable members across that
the rule exists in the united states
that even if it didn't exist in canada
they would have to have it in order to
enter the united
need st talk about how to get out of
this pandemic that means following
public health guidelines that means
getting vaccinated and yes it means
talking calmly and rationally about what
are real solutions instead of trying to
be incendiary and try to elevate a
situation that is not about the pandemic
that is about politics
well thanks to that member i see the
prime minister is still in hiding and
that member's mansplaining to me how to
stay calm and rational which i don't
appreciate mr speaker canadians have
suffered they followed the rules they've
done what they were asked to do we can't
have a slow and drawn-out process of
reopening just because the prime
minister is hiding and in denial dr
moore in ontario said recently i think
we have to start to understand we've got
to learn to live with the virus in
canada living means living freely will
the prime minister follow the science
follow the advice of experts and assure
canadians that he'll be removing all
federal vaccine mandates quickly
[Applause]
mr speaker for two years canadians have
dealt with a global pandemic that has
stressed all of us there is not a
canadian who has not gone through an
incredibly difficult time the question
that we ask on this side is what is the
science
the rules say that we stop at three
o'clock we've been very flexible going
beyond that i'm sure we don't want to
cut off any questions
because we can't hear anything
the honourable government house leader
from the top please
mr speaker we need to follow science we
need to very closely look at what is the
best way to get out of this pandemic
using evidence not politics we are not
in a place where we can afford to play
games with public health instead we have
to take each step one at a time